like I like seasoned seasoned food like
I hate bland food okay so I season my
clothes a
lot one of my homies told me like after
I finished he and I played it for him he
said man if you put that out man your
career is over
[Music]
that's like one of the the coolest
things about the recording like I'm
actually listening to myself be a baby
at something you know be a baby at this
new machine that I've never
[Music]
touched feels
like 80s doctor's
office I think it's Cozier than that
psychiatrist office psychiatrist office
there we
[Music]
go that's amazing man a thank you
man what's up man what's up bring it in
bring it in I like the shirt oh thank
you thank you very much yeah yeah you
know stra
yeah just trying to be like you it's
strip time be like you get your stripes
yeah yeah we should make it clear that
you actually use this lrat yeah yeah
this is uh lerat uh not too far from my
house how'd you end up out here I was
making a move from from New York and it
was really supposed to be like a like a
six-month kind of you know
reset you know come to California get
some sign hey hey what is that I got it
from a Ramsey's the Great great museum
in San Fran we went to this thing um and
I bought this just as and now he's just
the the laundry guardi he hangs out like
I sit him in the in the the wi seal of
my car like me and my son kind of like
and I think seven may have put like just
a plain rubber duck and then when I saw
this one I was like yeah we going
beautiful we going to freak it like
that's the Egyptian so like your son a
little bit with you too which is
beautiful I think people would be
surprised to know that you go to a
laundry mat to do your laundry yeah but
but only for that kind of convenience
thing and is fun for me because it's it
gives me a chance to kind of uh to be
out in the world and like when I'm
putting clothes in the dryer I usually
go out in the alley and practice you
know I play my instrument out in the
alley and it's just something to do to
get out in the sun a little bit what is
important about being out in the worlds
uh meeting people like I met this old
lady here um she was from Vienna I had
my bass clarinet at the time and I was
kind of playing and she says uh the your
music the music that that you're plan it
reminds me of my old country we sparked
up like a real cool friendship and she
was like if you come here next Saturday
I'll bring you all of my old record
collection of classical music from
Vienna and she told me a time to meet
her but unfortunately I was late and so
when I came I she wasn't around so I
hadn't seen her so I'm hoping she's
still alive you know do people clock
that it's you when you're here no she
she didn't know who I was it's kind of
like some people may recognize and like
oh man that's cool but it's not like
crazy like I kind of like what my life
is where I can where I can come and do
this you know what I mean like a lot of
my contemporaries like I kind of feel
bad for them you know because we got
children and like sometimes like some of
these people can't even go out without
having Paparazzi follow them and it's
like it's not that's that's a whack
that's a whack ass life man like I kind
of like some normaly even though it's
not normal but I came from that like I
used to hang out at you know the lrat
like when we didn't have a watch wash
and dry at at our house my mom worked at
the beauty salon so it's like I'm in
these places social kind of situation
you know yeah when you say normaly what
do you mean by that walk with your
family and not have people follow you
and chase you and you can't take your
kid to the park and play because people
will follow was your life ever like that
at certain times uh I think maybe at the
height of at the height of outcast um
over like years of like letting it
simmer a little bit and I'm older now so
a lot of people they see me like you
look like him but nah nah that ain't
3,000 so it's like it's funny cuz it's
like when you're
19 you're probably working towards like
anything but normal you know you're
working towards like let's be successful
let's let's let's see where this can go
and then you spend the back end of it
trying to work your way back to the
there life you want what you want to you
don't want it me and big boy used to
literally pray every night but Lord
really you really we just want to be
good rappers that's that was our prayer
it was called like a rapper's prayer
like Lord we really just want to be good
rappers and we did that and it's kind of
like now we're seeing that it's happened
I love that it's happened like I don't
regret any of that but it's kind of like
now that I'm at a certain level I miss
certain things about normaly and like
I'm an only child so I've always kind of
been to myself anyway I kind of like my
solitary kind of chill life and I I
think you do have a choice but you can
still live the other way if you wanted
to you are you ever like tempted to like
that's the that's the problem the
balance like I do have an urge because I
want to create things like I'm I'm
happiest when I'm creating things and I
was talking to my manager and publist I
had to really ask myself do you want to
possibly be famous again like do you
want to turn it up again and I was like
uh well I'll just put the record out and
just don't do any press for it or
anything like that but then it's kind of
a disservice to the music because I want
people to like check it out I want
people to hear it I had to find some
balance
we've been a little koi you have a whole
flute album now uh I wouldn't call it a
flute album it's an album but I am
playing wind instruments uh sometimes
it's native flutes uh sometimes it's
digital wind instruments which I
actually discovered right before we
started recording the album some of the
song what you're hearing you're hearing
me go through patches on the instrument
and uh you hear me figuring the
instrument out so it's new which I
thought was really cool uh to me that's
like one of the the coolest things about
the recording like I'm actually
listening to myself be a baby at
something you know be a baby at this new
machine that I've never touched a
document of this exists it has a name
yes new blue Sun new blue sun is the
album many people will ask why it would
wi album I ask myself why anything like
why why did we record these albums
before in my career like it's just kind
of those are the things that came you
know um I would say it's probably this
felt more real and authentic to me like
cuz I don't stop trying things like I
always try you know recordings and I try
vocal things uh I even try to jot down
ideas and lyrics here and there but none
of that just none of that excited me you
know it always it it kind of felt like
like I'm trying to do a thing you know
what I mean and I don't like when I'm
trying to do a thing it just felt
inauthentic and this felt like the
realest I could be at the time people
who like pay close attention know that
you're you're creating all the time this
this the first thing though that
actually is making out in the world I've
actually played some when things that
I've put out in the world that I call
myself another name under different
artists that are out there that you know
I've just kind of testing it out in a
way wait so you have Anonymous wind
recordings out there already Yes okay
yes from known artists really and and
they've been cool about keeping it
secret yeah I wasn't sure how to present
the win thing because I would just be on
the street and play cuz I I play like in
nature a lot I just play hiking walking
um in the city wherever and what started
to happen was people started kind of
like filming me on the cell phones and
posting it and making beats out of it
which is cool to me but um yeah I was
trying to find a way how can I share my
love for discovering this wind
instrument with more people like yeah
where it's just not this kind of where's
wo there's this dude planing kind of
thing so uh and approaching I knew I
wanted to do a wind-based album but I
didn't really know what I wanted to
sound like I had influences I had ideas
and I what were the influences uh
influences ranging from cold train to
Philip Glass to uh Steve Reich it's a
very intimate record I've heard it it's
like getting a very like luxurious and
expensive but very like tender mental
massage nice I'll take it I describe it
as just like pure like breathing you
know and and living in the the way it
was recorded it was all improv and
spontaneous so we were living it what
you hear on the record is how we heard
it as we were doing it it wasn't planned
it wasn't like hey we going to we're
going to do this we're going to do these
course and we're going to we only talked
about feeling you
know are you apprehensive very very very
apprehensive do you feel like
that played into decisions you made
about Outcast too I think uh just in
general when it came to figuring out
what we would do creatively and where
where my Creative Juice is coming from
within Outcast like there there was a
certain point where I just didn't know
where else to go you know I didn't like
even now like people think oh man he's
just sitting sitting on wraps or like
he's just holding or holding these WS
hostage like I ain't got no RS like that
like it's it's it actually feels
sometimes it feels inauthentic for me to
rap because I I don't have anything to
talk about in that way like I'm 40 8
years old and not not to say that age is
a thing that dictates what you rap about
but in a in a way it does and like the
things that happened in my life like
what do you talk like I got to go get a
colon oopy like what do you like what do
you rap about you know what I mean like
my eyesight my eyesight is going bad
like but you're not you're not just any
rapper like you're a top five top you
know to many people to me it's like
you're basically being like I have a
very beautiful sports car in the garage
but I choose ever to to drive it you
know which is which is your talent
talent is one thing but honestly it's I
think timing and momentum is more
important than talent and the energy of
it like Talent it's a lot of people with
talent and we seeing that now like
there's so many dope people on the
internet like that are just raw but it's
your timing it's what you're talking
about it's if you're catching the
Zeitgeist of what's happening in in the
world and like my goal is I want to
connect I'm not talking about nothing
that I can't connect with and it have
you tried it's no it's no use yeah I try
all the time like I'm open to producers
now like the young producers and I get
Beats all the time like and people send
me songs like to get on remixes and
stuff like that but I don't be knowing
what to talk about most of the time you
know do you think that's about
expectations or or or lack of
self-belief like where do you think that
comes from like I think you're your best
and worst critic and I only work on
feeling feeling is my only barometer of
what I'm doing like I don't feel like
I'm the best rapper I don't feel like
I'm the best producer I don't feel like
I'm the best singer actor none of that
it's just for me my gauge is feeling and
that's always been that way even with an
outcast like if it felt right I ain't
care what other people thought if it
felt right it was like I ain't going to
argue with what it feel like and if it
don't feel right to me which it hasn't
in a while like when it comes to rapping
or vocal you know type of music I don't
do it the song is more important than
the music is more important I was
looking at the song titles I wanted to
ask you about a few yeah for sure the
first song is called I swear I really
wanted to make a rap album rap and
quotation marks but this is literally
the way the wind blew me this time in my
mind I would love to make a rap album
like I would love to make a rap album
but this is what came at this time and
it felt authentic one of the things
that's so great about you as a rapper is
the directness and and the way that you
just you would talk about your life so
when you said yesterday I don't know
what to talk about now I was like how is
that how's that possible I was once in
the studio with a with an artist a
younger artist uh Tyler Creator uh and
we were talking about rapping as you're
old and I I was kind of telling Tyler I
was like man I just don't know what like
I'd rather write a book or something at
this point like I don't know like you
got to do it and I was like why he was
like because it shows us what we can do
when we get to that age but to make it
into a entertaining song to where it's
just just not self-serving or it's not
just like there's a part of entertaining
someone else too I know I joked about
yeah having to go get a colonoscopy and
all this kind of stuff and that's a real
thing in my life but to make that into a
song or why not like yeah of course but
I got to make it into a song that feels
good as a song but your track record as
making people feel good through song is
track record is one thing the right now
is a whole another I can't put anything
else out in the world if I'm not excited
about it cuz how can I expect you to be
excited about it how can I expect you to
think oh this is raw a this is fresh I
don't feel that way like what's that uh
that saying with that drug addict say
they say well the longer I'm out of it
the better chances I have of staying out
of it so that's not what America wants
to hear I no I'm staying but it it feels
that way like as I keep going like it's
like you keep slowing down too like
people don't understand there's a
physicalness to to rapping I always say
it's like it's like being a boxer like
you got to think it's think the genre is
big enough to Encompass all of that look
at the the greatest boxers now what do
they do they do exhibition fights every
now and then but they not stepping in
the rain ring you know what I mean what
if rapping wasn't boxing what if it was
but it is though that's what I'm saying
it is partly physical partly mental when
boxers when they about to fight they
have to train so if I were to make a rap
album the best thing I could probably do
is just be around rappers you know what
I mean that's not part of your life
right now really yeah it's not even like
I don't even like going to the studio
and just hanging out with smoking
all day you know I just I just it's got
to be weird to have all that energy
directed toward you people coming up to
you on the street or whatever and be
like do this do this do this and you're
like I'm not going do it I wish I could
answer them man that's a lot of cosmic
pressur like being brought to bear on
you it is it is and then that's to that
point that that title the first song
yeah I'm kind of addressing it in a way
um yeah I think so
yeah like for me like washing is kind of
like cooking like like I like season
seasoned food like I hate bland food
okay so I season my clothes a lot we're
in our uniform era is that right yeah I
guess you definitely can call it a
uniform it's easy for me like it's kind
of like even when I when I look around
now and I look at kind of what's
happening in the world like everybody
turned up in the late '90s and 2000s our
contemporaries were looking at us crazy
like who are y'all like y'all are from
another planet now the planet is here
you know like all all the kids are
turned up you know like which is
beautiful I just love this work Weare
kind of stripes and these overalls they
kind of they're very comfortable I call
them like a dope baby clothes you just
feel like really comfortable and snug
and like you have places to put your
hands this is yours these are yeah what
is the brand called from now on they
will have no choice but to call us the
ants this is a work Weare brand for sure
and like when you look at ants it's like
they're always like working I'm at the
stage where I'm loving to do things with
my hand hands yeah you know and things
that I can do when I'm 75 years old or
when I'm 80 years old and the outfit
reflects that yeah I mean like I don't
think about clothing like I'm I'm at
work like I'm actually drawing or
painting in these I still love it that
like the young kids they'll come up like
oh man your fit is fresh like oh okay
thank you man do you feel like the
uniform is a reminder to your self about
the differences between now and say like
the year 2000 it's actually the opposite
it's not a reminder at all it's a
forgetting I don't have time to think
about clothing some people like go into
fashion fashion like I want to be free
and like do all these things there's
certain freedom in that too but there's
also a freedom and not having to think
about it at all what do you do while you
wait usually when you're here uh I
usually go in the alley and uh I play I
don't mean to be forward or ask for the
art for free but could we do that I'm at
a point now like if somebody in the
street was would to were to ask me like
man could you rap like could you say
something it feel weird like like I have
to like get my mind like you have to get
in rap mind or rap mode but people ask
me hey can you play I like yeah let's go
yeah let's play Let's go yeah let's
go
yeah
[Music]
that's amazing man ah thank you I'm just
kind of feeling what's happening at the
time so I'm just kind of making it up as
it as it go like even the the new album
was completely uh improved and made up
just a discovery path every time so you
never know what patterns you will play
you never know what me Melodies you're
going to play you on the tight rope at
that point so it's like you got to do
something it's very interesting that
I've never been a rap freestyler I just
think too much to Freestyle you know but
this is somehow accessing like a
different part of the brain yeah I'm not
thinking at all listening more than
anything like listening and responding
so when I started playing it was kind of
a thing like if you didn't know of my
history if you didn't know of album
sales if you didn't know of Records you
know accolades anything like I I was
getting real responses from people that
didn't like actually people would come
up and give me money like yeah are you
aware of the clips of you playing your
flute various places became aware of it
and it kind of made me more
self-conscious because it became kind of
like a game I I I remember I was in
Philadelphia and someone came up and
they was like you know it's like a game
now like an actual person they were like
you know you know we try to spot you and
he told me I was like Ah that's kind of
it's kind of weird now you know cuz at
first it was kind of like I would just
walk for miles and miles and play and
just kind of duck off in places but now
it's like it's become a thing being
famous is just people don't want to say
it like it is a great blessing like I'm
I'm actually blessed to be able to
create in front of people and get ideas
off that's the biggest blessing out of
being famous but being famous really
sucks man like it's so unhuman like I
can't remember his name but there was
this classical pianist that said it's
actually unnat unnatural and actually
detrimental to a human to have that much
admiration because it actually changes
the way you think it changes the way you
move you know like there's 100 people on
the planet Earth who were like as famous
as you at one point you know like the
experience that you've had and know very
few people know you're like an astronaut
in that sense you know I'm coming to
grips with it I think because I'm older
now like I really see it as I'm just
being used for something you know what I
mean and I can just I'm happy that I'm
being used in a greater scheme like I
kind of have looked at my whole career
and looked at where I am now and I kind
of feel like I'm a catalyst kind of
artist where I'll do a thing that I
naturally do and then you know people
see it and then the reaction of that
spawns other things to happen you know
what I mean so I'm always watching well
how am I how am I being used like you
know yeah what's happening like what's
what's going on right now you know and
you can't be mad at
that and then I want to ask about one
more the last song Dreams once buried
beneath the dungeon floor slowly Sprout
into undying Gardens yeah yeah that uh
that song which is the last song on the
album Just for information that is
actually the first song that we recorded
as as as a a group we're creeping along
and filling it out and it just felt like
this Enchanted kind of Garden at first
and so the title is kind of referencing
that Enchanted Garden thing but it's
also like I wanted to kind of like go
back to the very beginning so I wanted
to like pinpoint the dungeon the dungeon
where I'm from you know with myself
Outcast Goody Mob organized noise and we
started in Rico Wade's basement and it
was dirt like it was actually it wasn't
a floor it was actually a crawl space
where the musical equipment was and I
just felt like um there was a
continuation like I always wanted to not
it's not a separate thing it's a
continuation from where we started you
know so everything kind of goes back to
the dungeon when you look back at it
yeah we were kids and you know we were
different in high school but even you
know choosing the name Outcast it was
like
okay you kind of don't you just don't
fit in really and I've really felt that
way even outside of music just kind of
in my life like I don't really feel like
I belong to any sect I don't feel like I
belong to the young rap crew I don't
feel like I belong to the Aged adults um
yeah I've just
never yeah I just don't feel like you
fit in anywhere so you just kind of got
to take that and just it is what it is
you know I watched the clip of you guys
being booed at the source Awards this
morning
you look so young oh yeah yeah we were
we were youngans man are those fun
memories when you look back on them at
that time oh yeah man they like those
times were the best times ever man like
and you wish you could get them back
like you wish you can all go back and
sleep on the dungeon sleep at on the
floow in the dungeon you know time moves
on and Things Grow things change
families come new generations come uh
Generations after you come even
musically you know know even looking at
the landscape of music now like I'm so
happy and blessed that I'm still alive
to be able to see like a lineage you
know to see it like to be clear yeah to
I I see it and I hear it because a lot
of these guys actually like reach out
and like we we we talk and I think uh
lineage is important in any art form in
anything because I think you do a
disservice if you don't tell people
where things came from when I'm making
music I always feel like oh I wonder
what uh what George n would think or I
wonder if if Jimmy was here what would
he think you know or I wonder what would
Prince think you're only as good as the
people before you yeah it's just true
because those are your building blocks
and I don't care who you are and it will
always be that way and it will just keep
going and that's it's it's it's
gratifying to know that your life has
had meaning for someone or a group of
people and for such a long time I mean
like I was
saying I see how young you are in that
clip I said like God these guys were so
successful so young you know I do you
think about that like did that what kind
of effect did that have on you it was a
blessing to be successful that young
like I think our career is kind of
interesting because uh since our very
first album we've gone platinum and just
kept Rising like so next album was
double next three next four so it kept
it just kept Rising I think you're 13x
today I heard yeah I recently heard that
which is so
crazy so so so cra bestelling rap album
of all time it's something in it cuz I'm
always kind of trying to figure out
what's the the bad in I don't know I'm
just a negator we haven't taken a
fall you know what I mean and I think
sometimes you build character or you
build something by failure idow may have
been our slip you know you you never
know the only thing you can do is be
honest about what you're doing at the
time because what you don't want to
happen you don't want to fall or fail
when you were trying to mimic something
or trying to appease someone else is
that what keeps you away from Outcast
now and I think there's a certain
chemistry that uh that me and big boy
have I think people don't understand
that chemistry changes Outcast was a a
true chemistry the elements we had were
not supposed to go together a lot of
times you know but it's something that
and I think they call it Rocket Fuel
like when you have these kind of forces
that may be opposing but they're go
going for the same goal but they kind of
get this
this kind of reaction to each other and
it makes magic but as as like people
like me and big boy like like we still
tough you know like it didn't hadn't
changed it it'll always be that way
because we were we were friends first
like we weren put into a group together
anything so we'll always have that but
plenty of people would get especially
since I think at least for years the
understanding was that he would have
kept going if you would have oh no big
man big boy is big boy he is on it like
he's he's back tomorrow yeah he is the
biggest cheerleader like for Outcast big
boys oh man we the greatest you
know he's he's he's the Muhammad Ali
kind of like the love between you guys
is very real cuz I think that that
energy those different goals would have
split other people up not just as a
group but as like two human beings I do
know that I'm not the controller big boy
is not the controller of any of this we
couldn't have planned where we are you
know so we can't plan an ending you guys
did reunite one time to play Show 2014
yes I haven't been on stage in damn near
15 20 years so it's like it was odd for
me and actually right before the show
you see Paul McCartney walk and go to
the left side of the stage and then
Prince walks to the right side of the
stage I'm
like what the man and you know
there's new technologies like earbuds
and like I never used earbuds in my
life like we were always just in front
of the monitors are listening to the
speakers so if you watching the
Coachella show like I got people in my
ear talking and and I'm it's like
what the hell is going on so halfway
through the show I was already checked
out like I was already in my bed at home
so I was just trying to get through it
and so um yeah the show happens and it
was a bomb night it was horrible for in
my eyes it was horrible the very next
morning I get a call from Prince which I
don't know him like that I don't know
how he got my number I I I I do not know
and first thing he says is you know what
your problem is you don't realize how
big y'all
are and then he was like you got to
remind people who you are and from that
point on like it's like okay is it weird
to live like where knowing that if you
wanted to next week you could be on
stage in front of 60,000 people it's
only weird in like the scale of of
thinking about that you know even when
we did the outcast 20 we opened up for
Rolling Stones on one of the dates and
i' never seen that many people in my
life was there like a mental adjustment
to be like Oh I'm I'm by myself again
I'm I mean there's been so many times in
my mind where I I thought I was done
yeah so it wasn't even like a struggle
it wasn't like oh what am I going to do
now like yeah there are time even still
now like doing all of this like I
remember a couple weeks ago talking to
my manager and Publishers I was like I
really had to ask myself do I want to be
just out there again like to do the run
to do the pr to like and I I really had
to ask myself and I honestly don't I
don't want to like I really enjoy my
life I I like being able to
do to do what I want as a civilian you
know uh when not just walking in the
world but at the same time I want to
promote the music so I'm only doing it
to promote the music like I'm not this
ain't no like no flex and forgive me if
this is like not something that's fun or
comfortable to talk about cuz we don't
have to but it's like you've talked in
the past about actually having some
amount of real social anxiety yeah it's
true and you and you and it never goes
away it's like it's not like a a cure
all kind of thing um it's just it just
becomes a part of life and you just have
to kind of like take a deep breath smile
a little bit and just get through it for
tomorrow that's the best I can I can say
you know do you think that's something
that de
and reaction of fame or something you
always had for sure for sure I think
that may have been a trigger like like a
traumatic kind of thing because it's
really unnatural to have that much
attention as a human you know or to have
that much expectation as a human I had
to adjust people filming you all the
time or just like coming up to you and
like and that was so weird to me like
very very we weird to me and I didn't
like it it made me not want to play at
all it made me not want to come out at
at all one thing a therapist told me he
was like well
son the thing that makes your art what
it is is the thing that you don't like
either so it's like what am I going
to do what are you going to do it's not
like I can change it yeah just kind of
rock with it do you feel like something
like the new record is like an attempt
to just change the terms of the
conversation in a way I will say it's
the most honest thing that I could do at
the moment and I feel really good about
it and one thing that I noticed
listening back at the album is it's kind
of a reset for a reintroduction of a new
volume I'm not trying to compete with
people on the radio like most records
that come out when you master them you
master them to the loudest that they can
go you know and I was having a
conversation with the engineer and a lot
of his engineer buddies they were saying
we've realized as Engineers that as
humans we've gotten as loud as we can
get in human history when you think
about that we can't get any louder as an
engineer people send you files a lot of
times they look like these thick bars
mhm solid bars when music look used to
look like that sure dynamic dynamic and
so on the record there's certain kind of
suggested listening you know tactics
like we would say you know listen at a
low to mid volume you know CU these are
not bangers when you listen to music now
do you hear your influence yeah where do
you hear most uh certain artists uh I
see it
visually um I see it uh more more in
spirit
and people pushing things and trying
trying things and I love I love the the
spirit like I think I'm happy that
people caught on on the spirit part like
you see Tyler and them you see like Teo
touchdown and those guys like you're
like what the coolest thing is it's not
like a sunning it's not like a copy it's
the next it's a lineage yeah it's a
lineage like these people got their own
thing like do you allow yourself to
picture how people might react to this
record when it's out in the world yeah I
do what do you picture I have a lot of
different outcomes and it depends on
different people like you may get
someone that cries you may get someone
that immediately starts to do yoga then
you got the homie that be like y'all can
to put some beats on that like my
friends don't always like my music which
is hilarious to me like one of my homies
told me like after I finish heyi and I
played it for
him uh he said he said man if you put
that out man your career is
over and in my mind I'm like damn but I
like this though like do you have
any other plans around it in terms of
will you tour or will you oh yeah oh man
I'm glad you asked that so the cool
thing about how we recorded it making up
the sound like everything that y'all are
hearing we made it up at at that point
and so the live performances will be
that again so we get to actually go out
and do it live and like I actually had
to go back and listen and relearn some
of the melody that I played but it'll
always be a completely new performance
every time have you thought much about
just being on stage again yes I have and
it's
terrifying it is terrifying it's a very
new experience for me like which is
totally different from getting on stage
and rapping some songs there's more
involved in what I have to do now than
rapping songs that I've written that's
kind of like muscle memory and Just
Energy and you're able to hide some of
the nervousness through your energy here
it's all in your face you're on a tight
rope the whole time like I can't hide
behind a beat that you already know or
hide behind lyrics that you already are
into it is what it is it's fun to do it
like when I'm when I'm actually playing
it's fun it's
[Music]
fun